Hello everyone, welcome back to another episode of the Grand Prixquel Podcast where we discuss
all things feeder series. On today's episode, we are going to be doing a quick look into all
of the F1 Driver Academies. Our hosts today are myself, Robin, Evan, Nova, and Peter.
So, I think we should begin with discussing what essentially is an F1 Driver Academy.
This is how teams can recruit and scout talent and they can essentially help with their pathway
to F1. I mean, it really depends on the academy as to what their support looks like. Some drivers
may give financial support or they may also help with training, providing simulator access, but
it really does vary depending from academy to academy. I know with funding, for example,
Williams helped Logan Sargeant a lot with funding and they essentially helped him move up to F2.
However, with Zak O’Sullivan, he lost funding from his main sponsor and was therefore unable
to complete Formula 2, so it really depends on the driver's personal situation and the team.
I mean, in the case of Zak and Logan, it was the same team, so that even shows how within the same
team they can vary from driver to driver. First off, the driver program I'll talk about is Audi,
which, I mean, if you know me, you know I'm a massive Freddie Slater fan, and Audi's current
program is quite small. I mean, the main driver really is only Freddie, who is, I mean, he really
is destined for Formula 1, I think. He's going to be the Nico Hülkenberg replacement for 2028 and
he's been fast in every level of racing he's ever raced in. I mean, in 2023 he won Ginetta
Juniors, did a few F4 races and took pole in one of them. 2024 absolutely dominated Italian F4,
also winning the Formula 4 UAE Championship. Last year he won FRECA, finished runner-up
in the Middle East, and this year he's currently competing in F3 and finished runner-up in Oceania
in the Formula Regional there. I mean, we're only really one race into F3, so we can't fully
judge, if I'm honest, but he's finished, he's currently P3 in the standings, well tied on points
with P2, I believe. He impressed when he was doing his, like, couple F3 rounds last season.
He did, like, what, two or three rounds, right? He did two rounds, he took a podium on debut,
I mean, he did Bahrain and Spa, Bahrain, he finished P2 in the sprint. He was fighting
for the lead the whole time as well, against Nikola Tsolov, who we'll get onto later,
and even in karting, Freddie is a top talent. He's won multiple karting titles, I mean,
this guy just wins everything he's in. In single seaters, he's never finished below P2 in a
championship, which I think is an insane stat, and I think he's going to continue that on in F3 and
F2, and I mean, he's very much one we're going to see in the F1, like, more of a matter of when
and not if, even though when we pretty much know he's going to do. There are rumours he's already
signed for Invicta for F2 2027, although that's not confirmed, because we know in the F3 Go Trident,
F2 Invicta, they're the best teams at the moment. Does anyone want to add on anything else about
Freddy, or have I, pretty much? I think that's everything. The only other driver who's officially
confirmed to be part of the Audi driver development program is Emma Felbermayr, who does
F1 Academy. She also did the first round of Italian F4, and she scored a point there,
and overall, I've been really impressed by her in F1 Academy this season. I mean,
she's leading the championship, isn't she? Yeah, she is, and I just hope that
Audi can give her some support, and of course, after this year, we can see her move up within
the single-seater world. I hope that her Formula Regional level series, we're going to see
more of her. And I do really hope that Audi continues their support of her, because we see
with a lot of the F1 Academy drivers, because in F1 Academy, each team has a supported driver,
so you often see that a team with a supported driver, but once they leave F1 Academy,
they just get dropped, so I really hope that doesn’t happen to Emma.
Yeah, I really hope they do continue their support with her. In terms of rumors,
we've heard that Daniel Miron, who is a karting driver, should potentially be joining the Academy,
and he's been pretty good. I really do rate him, and I think it would be really cool if Audi do
sign him. Yeah, I guess in the case of Audi that is slowly building up their Academy,
it only got launched, what, two, three months ago or so, so they’re just slowly getting the talent,
and a lot of the time, I think they have also had scouts at FREC. We heard that scouts during the
FEC weekend at the Red Bull Ring, so I think we're bound to see more announcements in the coming
months of who's joining them. And for our next driver academy we have the Ferrari Driver
Academy who I think are quite well known for doing their training camps with their individual drivers,
and they have supported drivers for quite a while. First up on the list would be Rafa
Camara, currently in F2. He's currently P3. Obviously, last year, he was the 2025 F3 champion,
the year before that, he was the 2024 FREC champion. Personally, I don't have much to say
about Kamara, I think he's good, but I do think that sometimes he is carried by the car.
The thing for me with him is like, before the F3 title, he wasn't really talked about that much,
and even the way he won the F3 title, and I mean it was, it was very much take a pole,
do nothing in the feature- in the sprint race, and then win the feature race.
He was in a Trident last year, which we've seen is very dominant in F3, and so
it's hard to kind of gauge how much of it is him and how much of it is the car, to be fair.
And so far in F2, yes, he is P3, but
he's not really moved me that much. Two rounds in, I mean, he's just kind of, if anything,
he's been a bit lucky with misfortunes happening to other drivers, I feel like. I mean,
maybe the Mechachrome will eventually hit him. And even with an F1, I mean, we've seen him
willingly do a test with Ferrari, so maybe later on in the year we'll see a few free practices he
does. We'd hope to see, because if he didn't even do those, I mean, questions need to be asked.
I don't want to delve too deep into rumors,
but there has been a lot of rumors regarding Ferrari and Haas, and if any of those drivers end
up leaving F1, I think Camara should be first in line to take an empty seat for next season.
Oh, definitely, and he definitely has the
Superlicense points to be ready to do it. Yeah, I mean, compared to his F2 counterpart, Dino
Beganovic, I think Camara is definitely the better driver.
And that tends to be the general consensus
when you see him next to Dino, is that a lot of people say that he should be the one getting the
Haas seat, which I do agree with. Dino currently runs P7 in the F2 championship, and he was the 2022
FRECA champion. I mean, with me personally,
I feel like he's not been able to fully maximize since that FRECA title. Okay, 2023, 2024, he's
with Prema in F3, who up until 2024, Prema were the best team in F2, but both of those years he
finished P6. Then last year in F2, I mean, he finished P7, outperformed heavily by Luke Browning.
I mean, this year he has started off strong. He was unlucky to get Mechachromed in Melbourne.
But other than that, I mean, he's one of those guys where he's just kind of there,
I think. And I mean, if you think about since he won FRECA four years ago, it's like you'd expect
to see more career progression, hopefully, if someone is kind of a top level talent.
I think it's really worth mentioning, or last year at least, that Hitech was a bit of an
interesting car to drive. And there was a whole engine problems as well last year with him.
But I don't still don't think that alone means that maybe he is actually a better driver,
because again, Luke Browning also had the same car, exact same car. And I mean,
he finished fourth in the standings. So granted, Luke also had like three other
races the season prior, but... Dino also did a few rounds in 2024,
I believe as well. So they both had experience from the previous year. And he had really good
performances the year before for DAMS, it was, I think. Yeah, it could have honestly just
been the Hitech car last year being bad. But again, if Luke Browning, we'll talk about them
later, nine podiums, one race win. I feel like that's an indication that maybe Dino's not
actually that good, unfortunately, for anyone who thinks he is.
Well, sorry to his fans, if you're listening to this, please don't hate us.
I think next up is we have Tuukka Taponen, who competing in F3, currently P17, but as I mentioned
with Freddie, we're only one round into F3, so we can't fully judge. And I feel like going into
last year into F3, I personally was expecting quite a bit from him, because I feel like, you
know, he'd performed quite well in all of his other previous series. He was P3 in FRECA, he
won the Middle East championship. He won that withR-ace GP, by the way.
But I mean, he only finished P9 in the end, so I mean,  just consistency he struggled with,
because he'd always be like, he'd very much be out of the points a lot, which ultimately is
going to be a downfall, and they seem to be consistently scoring points. If you're out of
the points, that's not going to do anything good for you. So I think for him, he very much just
needs to get a solid F3 season. I feel like I can't rate, really, Taponen. Like, no matter how much
I watch him, I just cannot rate him accordingly. Taponen just kind of is another one that feels
like he's there. Yeah, he's very far. I think he's very much reminded me of Beganovic so far. I was
expecting more, but I feel like he's trending towards that sort of level. It's still good,
but it's like, and he'll have a solid career somewhere, but maybe not quite within F1.
Then next up, we have Alba Larson, who is Ferrari's F1 Academy driver. And I think there's a lot of
expectation on her this year. Like, I think going in, she's very much a driver who F1 Academy hype
up a lot. And I mean, she's very much kind of like a young star, in a way. Young female star.
As much as I really, really like Alba,
I feel like she hasn't really lived up to the expectations. I mean, considering this is her
second season of F1 Academy, obviously she's not a rookie anymore, but she still continues to make
rookie mistakes. And I know she's still young, she's like 17. But she really, if she wants to
do well, she really needs to like polish off those mistakes. I mean, we saw in Shanghai,
for example, you know, with the safety car restart, and she just like ran off track.
And she really, really needs to learn from those mistakes, if she wants, you know, good results,
and if she wants to move up the singles into your ladder.
And the good thing for her is also like,
a lot of the F1 Academy that tracks they've been to last year, like China, they were there last year,
Canada, which they're going to this weekend, she was there last year. So I'd really hope to see her
iron at these rookie errors, because ultimately, they're going to cost her. And if you're struggling
at that F4 level, you can't really progress up to the Formula Regionalbecause it's just going to
be faster cars, the mistakes are going to be more costly. So I just hope she can iron them out. I
mean, we're only one round into F1 Academy. She also should be competing in some
rounds of British F4 this year. I'd imagine they could be the
Silverstone and Zandvoort round, because of course, there's a track to F1 Academy also where she's on.
I was a bit disappointed to not see her do somewhere like Brands Hatch and Donington Park,
given they didn't clash with F1 Academy at all. Yeah, I would have really liked to see
her do like almost a full campaign, minus obviously the stuff that clashes.
Aside from her, we have Niccolo
Maccagnani, F4 driver again competing in Italy. Currently, I think he's outperformed what I've
expected of him so far. I think we've talked about this
really recently with the Italian F4 recap episode, but I feel like he really has exceeded my
expectations. I did not expect him to do so well, because during UAE4, he was kind of a bit of a
reverse grid merchant. So obviously Italian F4 doesn't have reverse grids, so I wasn't really
expecting him to do very well, but he's done surprisingly well.
And I can say this for so many other of these
championships. They're only one round earned, so a lot of it is yet to be seen.
I'm pleasantly surprised by him, very pleasantly
surprised. I was a bit more scared for that lineup, but he's definitely pulling his weight.
Yeah, so I think as for the karting drivers,
I think Noah Baglin is a very notable name. He currently competes in OK Senior with Cart Republic,
who are basically Prema and he leads the FIA European Championship. He won titles, he won the
OKJ World Championships last year and Champions of the Future. He won WSK in 2024, and he plans to
debut in F4 next year. Unfortunately, because he turns 15 in March, end of March next year,
we're not going to see him do any winter series. He has so much going to be with one main F4
campaign from him next year, no winter series, but it's still going to be fun to see.
I made a joke about Noah Baglin doing
USF Juniors because he's 14 and the minimum age for USF Juniors is 14. So I said,
oh, Noah Baglan should do USF Juniors as a joke. But I think Dean Hoogendoorn took that seriously,
and we'll get into that later because Dean Hoogerndoorn is also part of a driver academy.
But I thought it was really funny that a driver actually just went from Europe,
Karting in Europe, to do USF Juniors, and he's doing the whole season.
They have Felipe Sala, who's another karting driver,
but there's nothing too notable about him, but he's solid. Again, we know with karting,
we need to very much see if they're able to translate into cars because
karting talent doesn't always equal car racing talent.
He does turn 15 soon, in July, so we could
potentially see him in maybe for a couple of rounds at the end of Italian F4, or we'll see
him over the winter. He does have that chance that Noah Baglin doesn't have because he's not old
enough. Yeah, I think. And the FDA have
actually sent quite a few drivers to F1, notably Jules Bianchi, Sergio Perez,
Charles Leclerc, Mick Schumacher, and Olly Bearman. There's definitely a path for the FDA
drivers to get to F1, and as we mentioned earlier, there is links with Haas, we’ve seen with Bearman
Bearman and Schumacher both were at Haas, Leclerc started at Sauber.
And also a lot of the FDA members have also
gone through to IndyCar, which I think is certainly something.
Well, that's Shwartzman,
Ilott, who else?
Armstrong.
Was Armstrong as well, yeah.
I mean, you have Schumacher as well now.
And in IndyNXT, we have Enzo Fittipaldi as well.
FDA is an IndyCar driver academy, not an F1 driver academy. You heard it here first.
We announced so much news on the Grand Prixquel
podcast. So much official news.
So you basically go FDA to IndyCar,
I mean, IndyCar is a feeder series to EC3.
What does EC3 feed it to?
Anyways, I think another notable junior team,
very much like Ferrari who are known for their training in a way, is the Red Bull Junior Team.
You see a lot of them on TikTok, on Instagram, you see the training they do with their drivers,
obviously do a lot helping their drivers with their physical strength, and their current reaction
times, that sort of thing. I think one of their most notable drivers is Nikola Tsolov,
currently leads the F2 Championship, and he's a 2022 Spanish F4 Champion. I mean, he is kind
of a meme, but at the same time, he's proving himself in F2.
Again, not to feed into rumors too much,
but he is very, very heavily rumored to be in a VCARB seat next year, whatever happens. I
obviously don't know what's going to happen, whether you have Max leaving the sport, or if
they decide to drop Liam, or if Isack gets dropped, who knows. But whatever happens,
Tsolov is supposed to be the next in line.
I mean, I think in F3, he didn't fully live up to expectations, but I think part of that
was just him skipping Formula Regional, which of course he went to Spanish F4 right into F3,
which is a very big step up. And like last year in F3, he was really in contention for the title,
until I mean, he went with Camara, with the Trident being kind of OP. But I think he very
much is kind of the main Red Bull talent at the moment. And in F2, he has been, I mean,
despite having bad luck, he's still leading the championship, and I expect to see more of him
upfront this weekend in Canada. And speaking of drivers who went from
F4 straight to F3, I think this leads us on perfectly to Fionn McLaughlin, who is in his
rookie season in F3. He won British F4 last year, also in his rookie season. He struggled a bit
during Formula Regional Oceania earlier this year, and he is currently P18 in the F3 Championship.
Obviously, again, it's only been one round, so we can't really judge too heavily. But he has been
struggling, and like we saw with Tsolov, it might take some time before he gets back on his feet.
But I do rate him, and I do hope to see him do well eventually.
I think it would be more of a case where this season it would be more him kind of getting used
to things, and we'll see more of him next year, and maybe towards the end of this year. Next year,
it's going to be very much similar to Tsolov, as we've mentioned, to give him time. Hopefully that's
TSolov, who only does two years in F3 rather than three years. But we just have to see, because,
I mean, with British F4 is a competitive championship, winning a title there is not easy.
Aside from him, in F3, we also have Ernesto Riviera, who unfortunately missed the Melbourne
round of F3 due to injury, but hopefully we see him back in Monaco. He has been testing a bit for
Campos over the break, so I believe he should be back for Monaco. Obviously, I'm not 100% sure.
I mean, he also competed with an Oceania Formula Regional P11 there, which is kind of meh, and
EC3, he finished P4 last year, 5th in Spanish F4 the year before. I mean, I don't really
fully know how to judge him, because I've personally not watched enough of his races to
fully judge, but I feel like when you look at the results, it's kind of just meh.
Red Bull has a lot of F3 drivers, so I'm going to go into the third driver, who is
Mattia Colnaghi, who, again, is an F3. He's currently P13 in the championship,
and he won Eurocup 3 last season, and I believe he came second in the Winter Championship that
year as well. He was a rookie, winning Eurocup 3. The grid, I don't really know what to say about
the grid, but it's still really impressive from him, I think. He also won the 2024 Spanish F4
Championship. So he has a really good record in cars, and I think he's a really good talent,
but obviously, again, for the third time, F3, it's only been one round so far, so obviously
we can't fully judge yet, but I do expect some good things from him.
Niamh I mean, next we have, looking at that EC3 driver, we have Christopher El Feghalu,
who is P7 in Eurocup 3 at the moment, again, only one round in, but he did win the sprint race
there. But my Spanish F4 last year was kind of underwhelming from him, only finishing 13th.
Wasn't he dropped by Red Bull, and then not dropped by Red Bull, and there was some
confusion on whether he was still part of the team, or whether he's a Red Bull athlete? What
is going on there? I believe he's still on their website,
that leads me to believe he's still with them, but it's a bit of a question mark, I mean,
and he does have the Red Bull branding on his race suit and on his car.
Yeah, but he uses his F4 race suit, I believe.
He may or may not be part of the academy,
we just have to wait and see. We don't know.
Their other Eurocup 3 driver is Enzo Tarnvinichkul,
who is in his second season of Eurocup 3, and he's doing his second season with Campos again,
he's currently peaked in the standings, again, only one round in. A lot of these championships
are only one or two rounds in, so we can't really judge anyone based off of their performances this
year. But he's the only person in the Campos lineup who is in their second season of Eurocup 3,
Heuzenroeder had a season in GB3, but it's his first season in Eurocup 3,
and Powell and Strauven are both rookies, so compared to the rest of the lineup,
I feel like he should be way ahead of the rest of them, but he isn't, so I don't know what to say
about that.
Yeah, now they have quite a few drivers in F4 who are all kind of notable prospects out here,
so currently in F4 they have Chiara Battig, who is in British F4, she's currently 12th in the
standings, and she's also a three-time Swiss OK Junior champion. I feel like I'm expecting, I mean,
P12 is still quite solid, but when you think about the team she's with, Hitech,
you'd kind of maybe expect a bit more. I don't think there's too much to say about Chiara, but
I mean, Rocco Coronel is a very notable talent, I feel like, he leads Spanish F4,
he also wasted his Junior champion last year, he's won karting titles, and did a few rounds
of Formula Winter Series, and he was able to run right with Dries Van Langendonck,
which I think kind of shows how good he can be, and I've quite enjoyed his racecraft.
I remember seeing him in quite a few FWS rounds. In FWS he's been able to defend for position, and
another driver who's quite good at kind of racecraft is Scott Kin Linblom, who like Chiara Battig
competes in British F4, and he's currently doing a lot better, he's P4 in the standings,
He was also in Ginetta Junior alongside Rocco last year, finishing fourth, and he's also the WSJ Euro
Champion of 2024, and yeah, I mean, I've really enjoyed his racecraft, we've seen it multiple
times, but in UAE4 he's able to come from the back to finish in the top 10, which is insanely
impressive, and I think he can struggle a bit in quality, but in the race he's able to make it
back up immediately, and I think he's a really kind of bright feature for the talent. I think
they have quite a few karting drivers, but we don't know too much about them, we have them,
sorry if I butcher this name, but we have Melvin Kalousdian in Ginetta Juniors, and also
Wynn Godschalk, Mason Robertson, and Josh Bergman, all competing in various levels of
karting, and like Ferrari, Red Bull have sent, I think Red Bull have sent the most drivers to F1,
I mean they've sent Sebastian Vettel, Daniel Ricciardo, Alex Albon, Daniil Kvyat, Pierre
Gasly, Yuki Tsunoda, Liam Lawson, Isaac Hadjar, Scott Speed, Sebastian Buemi, Brendan Hartley,
John Eric Vergne, Carlos Sainz, and Arvid Lindblad all to F1, that's quite a mouthful of drivers.
That is a lot of drivers.
But they're very much known for being cutthroat as well. I mean, they will get it to F1, but
you may only get two races as well. Yeah, you got half a season, yeah, good enough, you can go now.
But you've still got to do it, I guess.
Yeah, there's a couple drivers who have been dropped by Red Bull recently that I know my
fellow podcast members have very strong opinions on, so we would like to take a second to mourn.
I don't know how to say all these last names properly and I don't want to get killed by Alex.
We're gonna mourn Ollie Goethe and Tim Tramnitz, and I don't care if Alex decides that it's not good
because he's not here in this episode and that's his fault.
So our next driver academy that I will try to go through quickly is Mercedes,
and I'm really fond of the Mercedes academy, but I don't want to take too much time.
So a lot of their drivers are in lower feeder series, like all of their drivers.
There's not a single one above Formula Regional level.
So obviously, Formula Regional level, you have Rashid Al-Dhaheri, who competes in FREC.
It's his second season in Formula Regional.
And to be completely honest with you, I was not impressed with him up until this year.
I thought he was kind of, he's kind of, again, a driver who's kind of just there,
and I just didn't really rate him.
Like we saw in, he was really outperformed by Freddie last year in FRECA, I mean,
Freddie won and he was P8.
And even in Italian F4, the season before that, when-
Yeah, that Freddie also won?
Freddie also won, and Powell won the rookie championship and was P5 in the standings,
while Al-Dhaheri was 10th.
Yet Al-Dhaheri, he got promoted.
Anyways, I wasn't really impressed by him up until this year,
but in that first round of FREC, I was really impressed actually.
I was not expecting much, but he performed really well.
And if he continues to do well, I hope he ends up in F3 next year,
and I hope he, again, continues to do well.
There's not a lot I can say other than that.
He impressed me more than I thought he would.
Then we go into their 10 billion F4 drivers.
They really love F4 so much.
There are so many of them!
So first of all, I'll start off with Luna Fluxa, who competes in Spanish F4.
She's been doing really well.
It's only been one round of Spanish F4, hasn't it?
Or has it been two?
Yeah, but she really impressed me in the Winter Series.
I mean, we saw her take a podium, I mean, yes, it was a reverse good race,
but she was still really impressive that race.
Even during Spanish F4, there was a race where she was running in fifth,
but then she spun out and I got really, really upset about it.
But she's overall been really, really good.
She's in her rookie season, she's 15,
and I just really hope Mercedes doesn't send her over to F1 Academy,
and she continues to do mixed-gender F4 Series and move up to Formula Regional eventually and so on.
I think she has a lot of potential.
I think the main thing for her is, if she gets a solid qualifier and starts in the top 10,
I think she can stay there.
But yeah, I'm really excited for her.
And now if you look at their Italian F4 guys.
Yeah, we have their Italian F4 duo of Kenzo Craigie and Andy Consani.
Both of them are in R-ace.
The R-ace GP lineup in Italian F4 is three Mercedes-affiliated drivers and then two non-Mercedes drivers.
But anyways, so Consani and Craigie, I'll talk about them both together
because there's not much to say about one that you can't really say about the other.
They both did really well during the winter.
Consani finished P2 and Craigie finished P3 in his rookie season.
I think that's really impressive and I've been really impressed by him so far.
Up until Italian F4 started and Craigie decided he wanted to terrorize the entire grid.
But as you said, he was really impressive in the winter.
So as long as he doesn't recreate Pierre Gasly in Qatar, he should be fine.
They're both, I think, really talented drivers.
And they both obviously have the potential to finish
the Italian F4 championship, hopefully in the top five,
because R-ace GP seems to be more on pace this year than they have last year.
So hopefully I didn't just jinx them and I hope they do end up
in the top five in the championship by the end of the year.
And even Payton was really good.
She took a podium in F1 Academy in Shanghai and even in Italian F4,
she's been right up there the whole time.
She leads the women's championship and
this is her first full campaign in the single season, I believe.
Her first full season.
No, she did Italian F4 last year.
She's definitely improved a lot since her Italian F4 campaign last season.
And like Peter said, she leads the women's standings at the moment.
She almost scored points during one of the races, I don't remember which one.
She was P16 and I have never once prayed more on any one of the top 15's downfall
more than that moment because I really wanted her to score.
The three of them, technically Payton isn't part of the Mercedes Academy,
she's just their F1 Academy driver.
I don't think she's actually part of the academy and once she leaves F1 Academy,
I'm pretty sure she won't be affiliated with Mercedes anymore.
This is one thing I really dislike because it's like,
why do you make F1 teams sponsor an F1 Academy driver just for them to drop it?
It just feels so performative.
What's the point of it?
Give them actual support.
Red Bull do this as well, Alisha's not part of their academy.
Last F4 driver in the Mercedes lineup is Ethan Jeff-Hall who does British F4.
He is currently P2 in the standings and honestly, he is the only person in British F4 who I feel
like has been consistently challenging DVL because obviously we went to British F4
and we were like, DVL is going to win this by a mile and he probably still is.
But Jeff-Hall has been consistently close enough to kind of make him uncomfortable,
I guess.
He led the championship for a little bit up until that amazing third race in the last
weekend by DVL.
But yeah, I think he's a really good driver and I wouldn't be surprised if he continues
to challenge DVL and he's probably a clear favorite for second place in the championship
because I think he's quite a bit ahead of the group of P3 to P5.
I think he's close enough to DVL where DVL cannot have a bad weekend like we saw at Brands Hatch
and I think he's also definitely using his experience here of course in the British
F4 last year.
Again, had quite a good season there so he knows these tracks, he knows these cars well.
I think Mercedes also had quite a few karting juniors.
I mean, unfortunately Hayden's not here but Hayden we know is a massive Niccolo Perico fan.
Perico is insane by the way and I don't think anything I could say here will do him justice
so if you want to learn about him, Hayden discussed him a lot in our WSK Supermaster
Series episode so go listen to that if you want to learn about Perico.
But just as a quick summary, he's recently competed in OK-J, he was in OK-NJ beforehand.
He had a bit of a not-so-great first weekend in OK-J but he immediately, he's like 11 by the way,
but he immediately in his second and third weekends was up to speed with everyone else.
He's won a lot of Series and I don't think I can name them all.
But other than Perico, Mercedes also have Nuvolini in OKJ and Devin Titz in the Mini category.
And again, I don't know much about these karters I'm afraid
and it's really sad that Hayden is not here but they're all pretty good and it's clear that
Mercedes signed them for a reason. In terms of honorable mentions, I think we have to bring up
Doriane Pin and Fred Vesti who are both development drivers. Also Joshua Duerksen is a development
driver, I don't know why we don't have him in the honorable mentions.
I think this team basically means to help them with the F1 team and the simulator services.
I mean it's kind of a running joke that Fred Vesti is basically locked in the
Brackley factory during the simulator the entire time.
He's always in the sim, he's never out at the sim, he's always there.
And it was really nice to see also Doriane get a chance to drive the F1 car, I mean she tested the F1 car which was really cool
to see. And I think that with the Mercedes Graveyard with um.
The Mercedes graveyard. RIP Alex Powell, Noah Stromsted, Julia Montlaur and Yuanpu Cui.
I will not go into detail about the Mercedes Graveyard because I have talked
way too much about how I feel about Alex Powell being dropped by Mercedes but what I do want to
mention is about Julia actually because she's like 11. She got signed by Mercedes at the
beginning of last year and got dropped by them by the end of last year and I don't know what is
going on with that because obviously she's 11, she's in karting. Why do you sign a karter for a year
and then drop her? I understand for example if they sign a 17-18 year old and their performances
aren't up to what they want then they drop them after a year. I understand that but why are you
dropping an 11 year old? That is really sad. But in terms of like notable drivers that they
brought up to F1, obviously George Russell, Kimi Antonelli, also Esteban Ocon and Pascal
Wehrlein. There is a driver that I wanted to put in the Mercedes Graveyard as well but he actually
is with another team so I'll bring him up later. I think next up we have the McLarenDriver
Development Program. To be fair with McLaren that I don't know how much support they actually give
their drivers. It's not like you see a lot of them being posted online but I mean it feels a bit
wrong. This first thing I'm going to mention is in the Driver Development Program. It's Pato O’Ward.
He's been in IndyCar for multiple years. He's a multiple time IndyCar race winner. I mean
nine wins, 30 podiums, seven poles. I mean it feels a bit wrong because it's associated with
the F1 team where we know he's this guy is crazy fast and fun fact he used to be with Red Bull and
they tried to get him into F1 but you know these F1 guys, they don't like the American guys
well the Americans they don't have the super license points basically.
So I'm not going to go too much into him because he shouldn't be on this list, let's be honest.
I think we're all in agreeance there.
Yeah I don't know why he's considered part of the development program. I feel like especially
because he's like mentioned now that he doesn't want to go to F1 and I don't know if you've seen
his like Instagram comments and stuff but he's like constantly saying that IndyCar is better
than F1 now and that he just doesn't want to go to F1. I think that's really funny.
Watch him do another FP1 in like Abu Dhabi or Mexico or whatever again
and then still be like ah IndyCar is better.
I mean would you rather see Pato O’ Ward or Leonardo Fornaroli do a FP1?
That is also true. I mean also fun fact, Alex Palou, from also in IndyCar, was meant to
also be part of the driver development program until he had that whole contract thing involved
but he and Pato both would have been part of the driver development program which is really
strange considering Alex Palou is a four-time or now four-time IndyCar champion.
He's currently on pole for the Indy 500 as well.
And he's a develope- and he would have been a driver development program driver. He would have.
IndyCar Indy 500 Pole Sitter: part of the McLaren driver development program.
But there are two drives that are starting the top six for the 500 now that is associated with
this team. Anyways yeah so as we previously mentioned Leonardo Fornaroli is also part of this.
He is somehow a back-to-back F2 and F3 champion but like I don't think anybody rates him that much.
He's not even doing anything this year by the way. He's not racing anywhere. He's not doing
anything. He's just underwhelming. I think he's probably doing some simulator work with the team.
Maybe doing a few free practices later on. But like before his F3 title he wasn't even mentioned.
Like he’s so meh. He won an F3 title without winning any races. Like how?
We love Formula 2 and Formula 3. We love totally, totally fair series because that makes so much sense.
We love Mechachrome.
All hail Dallara and Mechachrome. All Hail Dallara and Mechachrome.
Next up we have Matteo de Palou who's in F3 also with Trident. I mean again only one round in
but he is only 26th in a Trident. He was really unlucky and also just didn't have a great qualifying
that weekend though. So again we can't really judge I feel. I mean if Freddie could finish second
and yes I will make this about Freddie whenever I can. I mean FRECA he was solid
finishing second but I feel like yeah. I mean he was solid so I'll give him that.
But next up I mean I think the biggest talent they currently have in Feeder series is Dries
Van Lagendonck in British F4. I mean if you've listened to our British F4 and our Formula
Winter Series episodes you know how much we rate this guy because he is insane.
He's just insane. I can't really say much more. There's so much to say that you can't say anything
if that makes sense. He leads British F4, a Formula Winter Series champion, took pole and
won on his debut F4 weekend and is a multiple karting champion winning multiple titles such as
the FIA European and World Championships. I mean he is definitely going places and I think he's
just going to try for who he could. He maybe skip Formula Regional and go straight to F3 next year.
I feel like seeing what happened with McLaughlin, I feel like taking it slow the same way that
Freddie Slater did. I feel like that's better for him than skipping Regional and possibly risking
not doing well in F3. I feel like taking it slow either way he's going to make it to F1 probably
so I think it's better for him to just take it slow, not risk anything, just gain the experience
That's definitely what Freddie does. I mean it's paying off for him. You don't lose anything by
taking it slow but if you skip a series level and then you don't perform that could look even worse.
I mean look at what happened to Tsolov. I mean people really underrate- I mean even I
was doing this where you were unsure about him due to the skip. The same kind of happened with
McLaughlin. But thinking with some drivers like Ollie Bearman skipped Formula Regional and went straight
to F3. He's now in F1 but it really depends on the driver and they have quite a few F4 drivers.
They also have Christian Costoya. He's only P25 in Italian F4. I mean he really struggled in
qualifying in the first round but I mean he had really good comeback in the races and
I think we're going to see more of him in the upcoming season once he sorts out qualifying
I think it's important to mention that the grid is made up of almost 50 drivers.
So to be P25 it's not like it's a grid of 30 like British F4 for example. It's a grid of almost 50
drivers. And like we saw him making up so many places in all three races so I think he definitely
will. I mean just sort that qualifying out and he'll be solid. I mean he's won karting titles.
He is probably one of the Prema stronger talents I reckon. Another F4 driver they have is Ella Lloyd
competing in F1. He's one of their F1 academy drivers. She's currently P6.
Oh again only one round in and she also finished fourth last year.
She's also doing British F4 this season. She did I think the first round and again I don't know what
rounds she's going to be competing in in the future. Again we assume she'll probably do
Silverstone and Zandvoort but we don't know. We also have, I mean I'll just list off their other
drivers. We don't have too much to say about them but we have also Ella Stevens in F1 academy,
Ella Hakkinen in F4 Central European Zone who is the daughter of F1 World Champion Mika Hakkinen.
She's been pretty impressive in her F4 debut and I can't wait to see what more she does over the
year. And we also have Gregoire Saucy and Richard Verschoor in ELMS. I think those two are more
drivers who maybe may be part of their hypercar lineup for next year because of course
McLaren is entering the World Endurance Championship so they aren't too closely linked
with the F1 team. And also they have Harry Williams in karting who I mean he was a bit
of a random choice let's be honest. I think McLaren has already sent quite a few drivers to F1,
notably seven-time world champion Lewis Hamilton, also Kevin Magnussen and Stoffel Vandoorne and
reigning world champion Lando Norris. Notably Nyck DeVries and Gabriel Bortoleto were also
part of the McLaren program at some point but they both left the program before their F1 debuts.
Bortoletto was in McLaren when he won F2 but then he left the McLaren program so he could join
Sauber slash Audi. Does he still have those links to McLaren do you think? Like is it possible
he could maybe leave Audi in the future and join McLaren? Possibly from what I understand
it is very much kind of a mutual thing like they let him go so he could join Audi, Sauber
whatever you want to call him. Really wasn’t like he was dropped; he chose to leave. So yeah he probably
does have still some sort of links and like I think he is just quite close with Lando Norris
who of course is one of their drivers. I think next up we have the Williams F1 Team Driver
academy which is I hate that name, terrible name besides the point. I think the star driver Luke
Browning as those who might know me know I love Luke Browning. He's also currently Williams's
reserve and test driver for this year. He's a former GB or British F4,GB3 and Macau Grand Prix
winners I guess. He was notably in his most recent F2 season or his only F2 season. He was a fourth
as technically speaking not a rookie but also a rookie whatever. He did this you know that
grid was Fornaroli, Dunne, Lindblad you know some pretty decent talent I'd say and also didn't- got
fourth with thatHitech which terrible car, absolutely don't know what that was. So I think no nine
podiums a race win as I mentioned earlier in the episode, pretty good. Right now though he is
Competing Superformula with Kondo Racing. He's currently P5 after a pretty good race in Motegi
in round two and he did that starting from P21 if I remember correctly which is again pretty
impressive though that was a bit of more unique race. It was pretty wet he had the same tires
until the very end and got P4 there so pretty decent off overall. Though his F1 prospects I
suppose are a bit more limited per se because he is like 24 years of age which you're getting a
bit odd that he's getting a bit of an unc there. I mean he's probably gonna be stuck in reserve
hell with Williams that's probably the most likely thing at least for now. He could pick up a Formula
E seat I mean it's a possibility. He was linked or well he did do a rookie test for Neom McLaren
back in 2023 rest in peace and it's, it's not like he 100% has those FE links still. I mean I guess
also you can consider maybe 2027 or 2028 likely maybe an F1 seat of Williams or maybe Aston because
Aston has an opening. He's previously done stuff of Aston through the BRDC from what I reckon
recall um but otherwise I don't think there's really much of um where else he can go other
than maybe other, um categories because he's quite simply put it he's a bit old he's a bit of an unc
Put it again he's 24 don't think any other teams want to pick him up really so that's just how it is.
I also only mention Aston Martin because um he looks awesome in British Racing Green. I'll put
up a photo somewhere here, great excellent that's why. I mean, I agree with Evan I think Luke is very
good I do like Luke and I hope we can see more of him with Williams. I mean maybe F1 debut please
Williams? Surely they give him at least one race one race somewhere. That's all I'm asking for
Williams. Who will he be replacing? Maybe Carlos Sainz decides that he can't um deal with Williams
anymore he tries to go off to Audi or something. Well look Alex Albon have you seen him crashing
out every weekend on the radio? Maybe one of them loses another appendix somehow they grow
another appendix and then they lose it again. The regenerating appendix in order to give way to the
reserve drivers. Exactly. But then Luke's gonna have to lose an appendix at some point he's also
gonna have- all Williams drivers currently have appendicitis or has had has had appendicitis in
the past. That's what he has to sacrifice. Look I think an appendix is enough for an F1 seat so that's
okay I suppose. Anyway here in Formula 3 they have Alessandro Giusti who is the 2022 French
F4 Champion. He's in his second season of F3 right now he finished 10th last year but I feel
like um he probably will do better than that. I don't know where he is in the standings currently.
uh so he currently sits 19th in the standings uh with no points but I feel like over the
course of the season considering he has experience uh in F3 I feel like he should
be able to perform better over the rest of the season uh but who knows I don't know.
The next Williams junior we have is uh Kean Nakamura-Berta, he's currently doing Formula
Regional where he he he sits P3. Last year of course he was the Italian F4 and E4 champion.
He would be higher in the FREC standings as of current if he had- if he didn't have that
atrocious race three. It really was a crash out to end all crash outs I don't know what happened
over there. I would love to know, I would genuinely love to know what happened in that race for that
to happen, but uh yeah Kean I would say not gonna glaze him. He is overall a very good driver he has
shown pace and a lot of the time I do just think when it comes to Kean, it is about attitude so
Yeah, Kean Nakamura-Berta, my favorite Williams junior. The doc says ‘I'm not talking about
Macau’ so let's talk about Macau. Ah no! You're mean! um no, you can talk about Macau weekend.
Oh Macau weekend oh my god he was at the quali race that he crashed with uh Seb Wheldon and then he
just couldn't start the main race because he was having some sort of mechanical issue or something
like that or he started but was like two three laps down, I don't remember exactly. I think it
was the mechanical issue that was his downfall in that race, but oh my days, Macau was- Macau was
a weekend for me. He moved on from the from the Macau weekend I guess and won Formula Regional
Middle East afterwards so I guess it's not all bad. Yeah he can come back from deficits and I
hope that he can do that in the FREC season as of right now. Moving on to the next Williams junior
we have Oleksandr Bondarev or Sasha currently competing in IF4 and actually during the winter
he did win the UAE 4 championship but prior to this did not have the best of results and even
coming out of the first IF4 weekend is not having the best result as of right now. I think he stands-
does anyone know where he stands in the IF4 championship? I will check real quick. Which is
quite surprising considering that all of us in our predictions episode for IF4 did say that he'd be
leading it out the gate being one of the people with the most experience in IF4. He's sixth in
Italian F4. Much lower than any of us actually expected when going into that championship but
I'm gonna give him- no, I don't know if I can- I'm gonna try and give him the benefit of the doubt. I'm
gonna say that he needs to guess reins in first before he starts vying for that podium but as of
right now slightly underperforming what we all expected of him I would say. Then we have our
Williams F1 Academy representative of Jade Jacquet. This is her first year in F1A however last year
she did French F4 where she placed 24th overall however she did claim women's trophy at one of
the rounds. Right now I can't really say a lot about her, I've not watched enough of her racing
to really rate her. In Shanghai, she did have that crash with Kosterman and to be completely
Fair to her I suppose it is, Shanghai is not a circuit that she's ever raced on but for now we'll have to
just see how the rest of the season goes and just see consistently where she ends up.
Moving on to who should be the karters but at the moment are not. We have Dean Hoogendoorn who
literally just turned 14 at some point last week and immediately after turning 14 he was
announced to be doing USF juniors. If you didn't know, the age minimum for USF juniors is 14
versus the minimum age for F4 which is 15. So like I said earlier on in the episode I made a joke
about Baglin doing USF juniors but instead of Baglin following that advice it was Hoogendoorn
who followed the advice and he decided you know what I don't want to wait to make my single seater
debut I'm going to go to America and do USF juniors and that's what he did. I am going to
be honest with you I did not have the time this weekend to fully catch up on whatever happened
in USF juniors because I am doing my finals but from what I saw he's been doing pretty decently
he was in the top 10 for all the races most of the races I don't know I remember he was like
P8 in one of them which is pretty good for someone doing his single seater debut. The USF juniors
grid is mostly rookies but at least those rookies have had a couple of race weekends before this
he is completely new so I'd say for a single seater debut he was pretty good.
He was also really impressive during his karting career he won the WSK Supermaster Series last
season and also the FIA Euro Championship and is also still competing in a couple of karting
championships this year where he sits third in the FIA Euro Series and first in Champions of
the Future. I don't have much to say about the other karters but they have Lucas Palacio and
Will Green who are both in OK Junior and they're both like pretty impressive. Palacio
was runner-up in the 2024 Supermaster Series was also runner-up in the Final Cup last season
and won the Supermaster Series last season as well and Green finished P2 in the Supermaster
Series this year and currently sits P1 in the FIA Euro Series and P3 in Champions of the Future.
So some really good talent in their carters and I feel like
eventually when their karters are old enough to do F4, I feel like we'll see some really good
stuff from them. Some honorable mentions for Williams. First off I want to talk about Victor
Martins who is a former Academy driver who joined for one year and then technically left but he's
still with Williams because he's a testing development driver now. It's a bit confusing
but whatever he's still part of Williams technically he's just not part of the Academy
directly. He also was an Alpine Academy member from god knows when, forget but he was dropped
by them 2024 from what I can remember. He is formerly a Formula Renault Euro Cup Champion
2020, F2 oh no sorry F3 Champion in 2022 with a yeah sorta okayish grid. We had Berman or
Colapinto O’Sullivan okay grid but not amazing. Now his F2 campaign he's done three seasons and
infamously every single time and he's been in every single F2 season he's always had something
going on whether or not it's ART getting shuffling him over, Mechachrome doing something, Dallara
F2 24 car or Alexander Dunne you know four common culprits for every driver as you might think.
He was fifth in his rookie season, notably the best rookie I'm pretty sure. Bearman was just
behind right behind him so pretty decent in his first year however with the new car from 2024
onwards he's been he was essentially slowly declining I guess enough to seventh in 2024
only three podiums and was pretty unimpressive but honestly that's not really any fault of his own.
I think that year he was plagued by the new car, ART didn't know what to do and Mecha Chrome was
also just being Mecha Chrome and then just last year he was 11th again not really any fault of
his own it's mainly thanks to the car Mecha Chrome and also Alexander Dunne loves hitting into Victor
so that's just how it is I suppose, yeah so F2's campaign not amazing not great but it is what it
is. Right now he's in World Endurance with Alpine, he's currently P18 with P11 finishes for his car
in the Six hour of Imola and Spa but Alpine is also exiting WEC at the end of this year so
don't know what he's gonna do now. It really is the Victor Martins luck. He always has something
going on he doesn't matter what state of his career he's at there's always something going
on with whatever's happening with his campaign and whatever. He should be in FE. I've heard
rumors saying that he might replace Norman Nato at some point this season possibly. I feel like
this season is too early I think Norman Nato still has a whole season left. Is is Nay-to or Nah-to? I don't know how to say
his name. The FE commentators say Nah-to so but they're also British so can you really trust
the British with that? I don't know the point is he is actually linked with Nissan in Formula E
because he did do the rookie tests earlier this year, I think he was the fastest or something along
this, I forget. but he was pretty quick in the rookie tests earlier this year. He would be
pretty good in FE so I think ultimately he will end up in FE at some point or later.
I would love to see him in FE. Yeah I think he'd be pretty good in FE. I just think it seems right
for him. He honestly also would have been great in F1 but team incompetence thanks to Alpine,
politics Alpine and whatever else was happening. No chance and he's also getting old enough that
no other team wants to really pick him up anyway so same with Luke Browning.
So we've got two Williams drivers who are both too old to go into F1 they're still linked to
Williams so whatever. Point is he's probably not making it to F1. FE is probably his next best bet
unless he wants to stay doing endurance racing and keep on going with hypercars like he is right now
but this is how it is. I guess another former academy member Zak O'Sullivan he was part of
the Williams academy from 2022 to 2024. Infamously I'm pretty sure- this is a random tangent- he's one
of the last non-James Vowles Williams era hires in terms of the academy at least. 2021 GP3 champion
second in F3 with Prema in 2023 and well his F2 campaign also flawed but this time not really a
fault of his own either as well. 16th overall but he did miss out on the last three rounds of races
I should say and that's mainly because his campaign was cut short due to funding issues.
My superman sponsors who've well he was also with ART that year so car not great
everything not great Mechachrome exists and Williams also dropped him the year afterwards so I assume
they weren't fully funding him, and just like Peter mentioned earlier in the episode, I guess
Williams just decided they want to fully fund him for whatever reason, even though they totally
could have but I assume it's to do with them dropping him the year after. He's currently also
in Super Formula and with Impul Racing, or it's Impul and in Super GT as well with CarGuy Racing.
He did start his Super Formula campaign and Super GT campaign last year. He was 15th with Kondo last
year for Super Formula, and 3rd with Super GT with CarGuy Racing, and he's currently 9th and 13th
in Super Formula and Super GT respectively, same with teams that I mentioned. Also worth mentioning
he is a simulator driver for Envision Racing in Formula E, so we actually have those Formula
E links as well potentially. He just doesn't really have- he's a great driver just his funding, not
really there, but clearly being at Impul already has already helped him heaps, I mean. Wwe've
only had really two actual rounds of racing in Super Formula, but 9th is pretty decent, new team
he's been qualifying better as well so I think overall maybe this might help him to- I don't
progress further perhaps, but I think he's really either you know linked to Formula E with Envision,
but eh, that's still like you know up in the air. At least though he's a bit more younger than the
other Williams drivers I've mentioned, he's not 24 years of age, he's 21 so still young-ish but
it's still a bit harder to get into F1 I suppose at that age when you're out of an academy and
you're not part of any teams, and so on so forth. And I guess also just to round it off, Williams
has also had a couple graduates we've got Lance Stroll, Nicholas Latifi, Jack Aitken, Logan Sargeant,
Franco Colapinto all have debuted with Williams. I think most notably Franco Colapinto is the only
one who's currently still on the- oh, Franco and Lance Stroll. Franco Colapinto and Lance Stroll
the only ones on the grid of them. I thought, I can't, I forgot, I forgot Lance Stroll existed
for a second but whatever yeah. That's the Williams academy. So moving on to the next academy which
is the Alpine Academy. So, the first driver I want to talk about and this is kind of really
funny, is Alex Dunne. So, Evan did mention him a bit when talking about Victor Martins, but Alex Dunne
is notoriously known for being crash prone, but before I talk about his racing I want to talk
about um whatever the hell the story was with his academy last year. So he is an ex-McLaren academy
driver. Um, he left McLaren voluntarily, because Helmut Marko offered him a position at the Red
Bull junior team. However, Red Bull- the rest of Red Bull did not want him there, so they had to pay
him a bunch of money to break his contract so he was just kind of academy-less for a while and then
he ended up at Alpine because obviously he couldn't go back to McLaren after he left them, because like
what is he gonna say ‘oh yeah, guys sorry I left you guys because I wanted to go to Red Bull but
Red Bull kind of ditched me so will you take me back?’ Obviously that's not going to work
right, so he's now with Alpine. He is kind of rumored to be next in line in case
either of the current Alpine drivers leave F1. He won British F4 in 2022,
2nd in Italian F4 that same year and also was second in GB3 in 2023. He was 14th in F3 in 2024
with a grid of you know, Fornaroli, Browning, Lindblad, Tsolov. His season was kind of unimpressive
but then when he moved to F2 the year after, he really- he did well. He was fifth in F2 in 2025, but
again he is very well known for being crash-prone, obviously the biggest um example was Monaco with
the, um what was it, 10 car pile-up that he caused with Victor Martins. He really enjoys crashing into
Victor Martins. Um, he's also crashed into several other people. At the beginning of this season he
crashed into his teammate, Martinius Stenshorne in Australia. You'd think after so many crashes, he
would you know learn to be a bit more careful, and a bit less aggressive while driving, but
that really isn't the case unfortunately. And the thing is he's really really fast,
but he's- he just crashes a lot and so it really hurts him, and I feel like it will- it'll really
hurt his chances in the long run of trying to get an F1 seat or like a good seat anywhere really.
And yeah, um, I feel like he could still eventually make it to F1, if you know Colapinto
or Gasly end up leaving Alpine. But also he was linked to NEOM McLaren when they were still in
FE. RIP NEOM McLaren- I really miss them by the way. but he was linked with them he did a couple
um rookie tests with them. Um, and I believe he was like rumored to be joining the team
back when they were still a team but now that they're not a team obviously he's not going
I think he’d could do pretty well in Formula E, he's very gen 2-esque driving where you just drive
and you don't care when you hit into people because Formula E, lovely category, apparently
hitting into people doesn't affect you at all because it's not F1 so aerodynamics
doesn't exist. He's very much- he would thrive in FE I think. He is a very Formula E shaped driver
I feel. I think GEN4, with the amount of speed GEN4 brings, I think he would do some real damage
on the grid, I fear. But that's what we love about Alex Dunne. Alex Dunne you want to go to FE so bad.
Imagine, you know how we said that Martins is rumored for FE, imagine that Martins together
in GEN4 FE. We're gonna get another Monaco, but instead it's both of them in FE. Anyways moving on
from Alex Dunne. Um, Alpine has two other F2 drivers as well with Gabriele Mini and Kush Maini.
There's not much to say about Maini I'm afraid, but for Mini I feel like he's a really good driver.
He just, for some reason Alpine doesn't have him do anything, like has he ever done a free
practice session? Not to my knowledge. And he doesn't do any like TPCs, he doesn't do anything. I don't
know what he does at Alpine but he's there at least, and he's a pretty decent driver. I don't
know where he is in F2 currently but he's had some pretty good races recently so he should
probably be somewhere up at the top of the championship. He did get his first ever F2 win
in Miami. Exactly, so he's he's a good driver. Unfortunately kind of overshadowed by the
existence of Alex Dunne, but yeah. Outside of F2, they have Nina Gademan who is their F1 Academy driver.
I don't really know what to say about her. She's in her second F1 Academy season and she's just
again, one of those drivers that's kind of there. We've said this about so many drivers but
unfortunately that is just how it is. Same with Kabir Anurag, who is in FREC, again not much to say about him.
Then they have Keanu Al Azhari who does Eurocup 3 with them, and he has been surprisingly really
good like going into 2026, I probably wouldn't have named him as someone to look out for. But
he was really impressive during the winter series, I mean he won the entire winter series. And I feel
like he probably would be leading the main Eurocup 3 standings, had he not stalled in
that first race. He's really good at overtaking and he's just really good and Hitech seems
to be really good in Eurocup 3, despite it- despite it being their first season there.
And then they have two uh karting drivers who- I don't know how to say their names.
Just say it and we ball because- no I don't think
What if I'll just put in post Google Translate saying their name, the Google Translate voice
can say it, so it's not you saying it. There we go, that's an idea. I think it’s Illie, I don't want to butcher their
names. The point is they have two karting drivers. They have two karting drivers. And I don't really
know what to say about either of them. I am not as invested in karting as someone like Hayden for
example, especially because one of their karters is in a series that I have no- no idea about.
So unfortunately I'm not the person to ask about this. In terms of honorable mentions,
we have Jack Doohan, who obviously was in F1 for about last season for, what was it, five races
until he got replaced by Franco Colapinto. About seven races. Was it seven? I didn't know, Wikipedia
is a bit weird, so when I was like I was gathering stats- well he did Abu Dhabi in 2024, yeah? Oh right
yeah, I forgot about that, I forgot about that yeah. Then he did how many- uh six races I guess, in
2025. He was part of the Alpine academy from 2022 to 2025, and was also part of the Red Bull
junior team from 2017 to 2021. If anyone has seen that video of him dancing or- dancing to whatever
it was, I'll put it up on the screen right now probably um video listeners. That's where it comes
from. The Drake song. Yeah um he was second in F3 in 2021 with Trident. Grid was decent?
They had Vesti, Martin, Sargeant, Iwasa and Hauger, who, Hauger was the one who won the championship
that year, so I don't know what that says about the- the grid, the quality of the grid. He was
sixth in F2 in 2022, and third in F2 in 2023. Again decent grids, 2022 had Drugovich,
Pourchaire, Lawson, Sargeant and Iwasa again. And 2023 again had Pourchaire, Vesti, Iwasa,
Martins and Bearman. So he was competing against some decent grids, but again he was kind of
in good cars so. He after, you know he got dropped from F1, he moved over to ELMS and is currently
competing in ELMS with Nielsen Racing in LMP2, and the team is currently 10th in the LMP2 standings.
He's also a reserve driver for Haas and is linked to possibly be part of the team
if Ocon gets dropped, but honestly I feel like it's more likely to go to Rafa Camara
so who knows. Also worth mentioning, he was going to be in Super Formula this year before he
crashed in all the testing at Suzuka. So Kondo, not very big fan of that but- Didn't he crash like
three times in the same corner? Yes, exactly and it was the same spot where he crashed in Japan
2025 in F1, fun fact! So he really hates Suzuka I think- I think he absolutely
loathes- he hates that place. Don't take Jack Doohan into Suzuka. Exactly. Also partly it was because he
was prioritizing Haas and ELMS so that's probably part of it as well. In terms of the future, I feel
like he'll probably just continue to go down the sports car path, maybe he'll go back to F1 but
honestly I doubt it. And I did mention this earlier, but there was a driver who I wanted to
talk about in the Mercedes graveyard except he's in Alpine now so he doesn't get to go in the
Mercedes graveyard, and that is Paul Aron. He used to be part of the Mercedes academy
but I believe he got dropped by them. I don't know if he got dropped or if he just left.
I think it was a mutual agreement from what I heard. Either way, no longer at Mercedes. He is
a test and reserve driver for Alpine and yeah, he had a decent F2 season in 2024, but also I wasn't
really watching F2 back then so I could not tell you much. He was pretty good actually I think he
ended up in at least the top three or four, can't recall, but he was pretty decent in 2024.
I think from what I can remember, he was in a Hitech as well and Hitech was actually
pretty decent that year for some reason so. And then to round off the bit about Alpine,
notable graduates to F1, the only driver who was part of the academy and joined Alpine in F1
was Jack Doohan. They also had Oscar Piastri and Zhou Guanyu who were part of their academy
however they did not join- they did not join F1 with Alpine, they left Alpine. I wonder why
Oscar left, wonder why he didn't debut with Alpine I don't know. I wonder. I wonder why. Can you pull up
the tweet? the um ‘I understand that with-’ it's up here right now for video listeners, you've got it
right here. And yeah that's it for Alpine. For our next driver academy, we have the Aston Martin
Aramco driver academy. It's an academy and a half, it is barely an academy. You've got like one two-
you got five people in here and they're all honestly sort of mid, and I don't want to be mean
but- one of them is Newman Chi. Newman Chi, Mari Boya. I think that says quite a bit about
the caliber with their academy I suppose. But really quickly we'll run just through everybody.
So in formula two they have Mari Boya- oh I can't talk about him seriously anymore.
Mari Boya he- he’s okay, he's not- he's not notable, I just don't know how he got signed unless he got
signed because he's part of the um Fernando manages him which I think is a thing. A14 yeah.
Yeah, so maybe that was part of it. But honestly Mari Boya, not great from what I reckon- I recall
he hasn't won any titles in his race in like racing other than karting maybe, I don't know if
he even won a title in karting, but that's besides the point. Eh, was okay in F3 and whatever and so on.
So, not great he's just there don't know why he's at Aston Martin, probably reasons for it
knowing Aston Martin as a team as a whole, bit of a weird team so. And then we have their F1A
representative of Mathilda Paatz. She's okay, she has competed in Formula Winter Series last season
and also is competing in Formula Winter this season. Did a couple rounds of Italian F4 last year as
well. It was- did a couple rounds of E4 as well. Um obviously, this- this is a second season
in F1 Academy, she's with Prema this year, last year she was with Hitech. I think, but last year
she was like wild- I don't know what she was wildcard something, don't know. I'm not Alex,
couldn’t tell you anything about F1 Academy, so. Uh, Paatz was a wildcard for in F1 Academy last
year, that's why she was with Hitech, so this is her first full season of F1 Academy. And then like I
said for the rest of their drivers Newman Chi in FREC, Ava Lawrence and Roland,
don't know how to say his last name, so I'll just say Roland, in OKJ. And I guess
honourable mentions, the Aston Martin driver academy: Jak Crawford, which has never actually been part
of the academy but he's- Aston Martin before they launched their academy which was last year with
Mari Boya, they sort of treated all the drivers they signed as academy members, it was- it's really
confusing. Yeah I just kind of assumed he was part of the academy. I don't know. Apparently he's not.
He's a test/simulator driver, he's talked about as if he is an academy member. I think a giveaway though
was when he did sign to Aston Martin last year or whatever year it was, when he was in F2
he obviously didn't wear any Aston Martin like branding or whatever, which Mari Boya- which
Mari Boya I think does to some extent? Also Felipe Drugovich can't mention, I think he was
probably one of the first academy drivers, not part of the academy- it's confusing whatever but
he is part of Aston Martin- he was part of Aston Martin then he joined um Andretti in FE just for
the 2025-26 season. I mean he's okay he got his first podium in Monaco last race, but um he's
interesting he's there that's Aston Martin for you. And I guess also we can mention
honorable mentions to the two other teams that we've not mentioned in the grid so far: Haas
They don’t have an academy driver or driver academy, I should say, at this stage. I think they have in the past?
Can't tell, a bit confusing because they usually grab Ferrari drivers as we all know.
I'm not sure. Yeah it's- Google and Wikipedia both are useless to me right now on on that so
when I was making notes so whatever. The only person they have that is affiliated with them
in a junior capacity right now is Kaylee Countryman in F1 Academy.
Don't know much about her because I don't watch enough F1 Academy. But she's not really technically
part of the academy she's like um, you know how we mentioned that Peyton Westcott and Alicia Palmowski
aren't part of their team's actual academies, they're just there for F1 Academy which really
really sucks. Yeah that's a bit unfortunate honestly but, I guess I mean, to be fair F1
Academy doesn't require you to put drivers into your academy, but it'd be nice honestly to have
at least those drivers have the backing or whatever. And then we also have Cadillac or TWG because
the whole Cadillac-Andretti, whatever is a confusing timeline and I have- or confusing mess
of companies, it's TWG but we’ll just call it TWG at this point. Um they are scouting for drivers apparently
even though they don't have an official academy as of yet at least in Cadillac side. Please sign
Alex Powell. I mean it would actually be good, Alex Powell I think- He's American they- it works. Cadillac
hit up Alex Powell, like right now please. Next episode we better see sign Alex Powell. Cadillac
you better be listening- I know you, I know someone who can access things is listening to this episode
totally. Exactly. Cadillac please sign Alex Powell. So we only have Colton Herta, as I guess their
academy driver in for Cadillac at least. He's in F2 now with Hitech, formerly IndyCar
you know totally normal pathway to go through, but I think he wants to get into F1, so it's the only
pathway he can take really without trying to win the championship in Indycar which is um,
a bit you know this person called Alex Pow-um, Alex Palou exists right now so a bit hard to do that.
I did notice you almost said Alex Powell, and there's probably a universe where Alex Powell
is a four time IndyCar champion. Alex Powell I think has been mentioned in this podcast too many
times that any Alex is just instantly Powell to me. So that's the Powell agenda working. Exactly!
I think this is also for the reason when Cadillac should sign Alex Powell, I think
the agenda works really well. Even like- exactly. Even though I’m talking about completely different Alex-
It's always Alex Powell. Other than like Cadillac, obviously Cadillac, TWG,
Andretti, whatever- whatever the hell is going on there Andretti has a couple junior drivers
of their own. Technically it's for the IndyCar team, but like honestly who knows. So they have
Seb Weldon and Zane Burgess. Seb Weldon is in FREC at the moment, I don't know where he is in
the championship but he's been pretty decent. He was originally meant to be with Prema
‘Prema's good bro calm’ but um, he left Prema went to MP instead. Um and Zane Burgess is kind
of just insane, he's in karting and he's just literally baby goat and yeah they're both really
good drivers! So that's it for today's episode, hope you guys enjoyed and I hope you learned something
about all these driver academies. On our next episode, we are going to be doing a recap of the
upcoming Italian F4, F1 Academy and F2 weekends so be sure to tune in for that, and make sure to
follow us on all our socials @grandprixquel on TikTok, Instagram, and Twitter, and we'll see you next time!